repasemos cómo calcular intervalos de
confianza para proporciones imagina que
tenemos una población y de ella nos
interesa una cierta proporción digamos
que nos interesa
la proporción de individuos que son
zurdos no conozco esta proporción así
que tomó una muestra de tamaño n y de
esta muestra puedo calcular la
proporción muestral peso hombre
la proporción muestral estima nuestra
proporción verdadera ahora quiero
construir un intervalo de confianza pero
antes de seguir ese camino
necesito establecer las condiciones para
la inferencia y estar seguro de que las
cumplimos esto ya lo hemos visto en
varias ocasiones la primera condición
para la inferencia es la condición de
aleatoriedad necesitamos una muestra de
la población que sea completamente
aleatoria la segunda es la condición de
normalidad ahora bien para considerar
que es normal se tiene que cumplir qué
por p sombrero esto debe de ser mayor o
igual que 10 y a su vez que n por uno
menos p sombrero debe de ser mayor o
igual que 10 todo esto lo hemos
mencionado en varias ocasiones y la
tercera es la condición de independencia
ahora bien hay dos formas de obtenerla
ya sea que las observaciones
individuales en la muestra se hagan con
reemplazo obra si no se hacen con
reemplazo nos podemos sentir bastante
seguros de que se cumple esta condición
si el tamaño de la muestra es menor que
el 10% del tamaño de la población
digamos que cumplimos estas condiciones
para la inferencia entonces qué hacemos
ahora bueno necesitamos establecer un
nivel de confianza un nivel de confianza
para el intervalo de confianza que
queremos construir digamos que es del
95% eso significa que el 95% de las
veces que hagamos este ejercicio el
intervalo de confianza que construiremos
intersec hará con el valor verdadero de
la proporción poblacional y 95% es un
nivel de confianza que se utiliza mucho
ahora con este nivel de confianza
podemos calcular el valor crítico y la
forma de encontrarlo simplemente es
observar una tabla zeta recuerda todo
esto es un repaso y con esto decir
cuántas desviaciones estándar por encima
y por abajo de la media de la
distribución normal necesitamos para
obtener un 95% de confianza y ya con
esto estamos listos para calcular el
intervalo de confianza
este intervalo será igual a nuestra
proporción muestral
as - nuestro valor crítico por la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral de proporciones ahora existe
una forma de calcular esta desviación
estándar de una manera exacta si sabemos
cuál es el valor de pep si supiéramos el
valor de pep esta desviación estándar
sería la raíz cuadrada de pep por 1
entre n pero si supiéramos el valor de p
entonces no tendríamos que hacer todo
esto de construir intervalos de
confianza así que como no podemos
calcular la con exactitud porque no
conocemos el valor de p entonces la
estimaremos la estimación de la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral antes conocida como error
estándar será la raíz cuadrada pero en
lugar de usar el valor real de la
proporción usaremos el valor muestra de
la proporción que sombrero y me quedará
la raíz cuadrada de peso obrero que
multiplica a 1 - p sombrero
todo esto dividido entre
la razón del por qué hice todo este
repaso y esto se ve con más detalle y de
manera más lenta en otros vídeos es que
veamos las similitudes y la situación en
donde construimos un intervalo de
confianza para dos muestras o intervalos
setup para una diferencia entre
proporciones a qué me refiero bueno
veamos este caso imagina que tenemos dos
poblaciones diferentes esta será la
primera y tenemos una cierta proporción
verdadera de personas que no sean
supongamos son sordas llamémosle p 1
y también tenemos otra población cuya
proporción verdadera llamaremos pedos
tal vez los primeros sean los
estudiantes de primer ingreso y la
segunda población sean los estudiantes
de segundo año
tenemos dos poblaciones distintas y
queremos ver si hay una diferencia entre
las proporciones de personas zurdas y lo
que haremos justo como lo hicimos aquí
es para cada una de estas poblaciones
tomar una muestra de tamaño n 1 para la
población 1 y de esta muestra
calcularemos la proporción muestral
llamémosla am p gorro 1 y para la
segunda población haremos lo mismo
tomaremos una muestra de tamaño n 2 ojo
date cuenta que n1 y n2 no forzosamente
deben de tener el mismo tamaño ese es un
error de concepción cuando se trabaja
este tipo de ejercicios es decir pueden
ser diferentes tamaños de muestra y de
esta muestra calcularemos la proporción
muestral
ahora después de hacer esto empezaremos
las condiciones para la inferencia estas
condiciones serán las mismas para las
dos las dos muestras cumplen la
condición de aleatoriedad las dos
muestras cumplen la condición de
normalidad las dos muestras cumplen la
condición de independencia y si ambas
muestras cumplen las tres condiciones
para la inferencia entonces tendremos
que calcular nuestro valor crítico
déjame escribirlo primero revisaremos
todo esto después tomamos nuestro nivel
de confianza y de allí obtenemos nuestra
zeta y con esto estaremos listos para
decir cuál es el intervalo de confianza
para p
1 - p 2 es decir el intervalo de
confianza para la diferencia entre estas
dos proporciones poblacionales
este será igual a la diferencia entre
sus proporciones muestrales p sombrero 1
- p sombrero 2 + - nuestro valor crítico
z asterisco por la desviación estándar
de la distribución muestral de la
diferencia entre estas dos proporciones
muestrales p sombrero 1 - p sombrero 2
ahora bien ya sabemos cómo calcular esto
y esto y esto y ahora como calcularemos
la desviación estándar bueno primero te
daré la fórmula y quiero que apreciamos
que esta sale de las propiedades de
desviación estándar y varianzas que
hemos visto en el pasado por lo tanto la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral de la diferencia entre estas
dos proporciones muestrales será
aproximadamente igual a la raíz cuadrada
p 1 sombrero que multiplica a 121
sombrero esto entre n 1 más de 2
sombrero que multiplican a 1 - peto
sombrero esto entre n 2
y con esto podemos sustituir la y
construir nuestro intervalo de confianza
y una vez más como interpretamos esto
bueno digamos que nuestro nivel de
confianza es del 90% y con este podemos
construir este intervalo de confianza lo
que significa que un 90 por ciento de
las veces que hagamos este ejercicio
nuestro intervalo de confianza inter
secará con la verdadera diferencia de
estos parámetros poblacionales pues la
verdadera diferencia de estas
proporciones poblacionales ahora de
dónde viene esta aproximación bueno
puedes ver algunas similitudes por aquí
esta primera parte es un estimado o es
aproximadamente igual a la varianza de
la distribución muestral de la primera
proporción
y esta segunda parte es aproximadamente
igual a la varianza de la distribución
muestral de la segunda proporción como
es que lo sé bueno observa si estás
aproximadamente la desviación estándar y
lo eleva al cuadrado aproximadamente
obtenemos la varianza entonces la idea
más importante es que la varianza de la
distribución muestral de la diferencia
es de hecho la suma de las varianzas de
cada una de estas dos distribuciones
muestrales
esta es una idea que quiero que te
lleves a casa
espero no confundirte espero que esto
tenga sentido para ti y que veas que de
aquí sale esta fórmula y así será más
fácil recordarla en los siguientes
vídeos haremos más ejemplos revisando
que se cumplan estas condiciones y
calculando intervalos de confianza y
valores críticos